I've got a couple of facts
about biscuits. Let's hear them.
Did you know that biscuits were
invented by Sir Morris Biscuits
in 1950-12?
And also did you know
that over 40 biscuits a year
are sold in Europe alone?
Did you know that in America
they're not called biscuits?
Oh. They're called the sidewalk.
Welcome to
The Great British Bake Off.
Don't go.
Last time, we met
our new Bake Off bubble.
This is it!
For Cake Week...
I don't know if I've ever fancied a
cake before, but I slightly do now.
David's upside down cake...
Ooh!
..landed the wrong way up.
I'm so sorry.
Don't worry about it, it's fine.
Oh, don't cry, it's all right.
Peter kept his ear
close to the sponge...
It's delicious. And it's witty.
..becoming our first Star Baker.
Rowan shot for the stars.
Inside is the temple
of enlightenment.
But came crashing down.
Say less and then do more.
Yes. Oh!
But it was Loriea
whose bubble-gum burst...
That's bone dry.
..as she was the first
to leave the tent.
Sorry. It's fine! Miss you.
This time, it's Biscuit Week...
Oh... with a sticky signature...
..that's tight on time.
What a disaster!
A tropical technical
that has the bakers bemused.
I've got no idea, mate.
And a brittle showstopper...
Ugh!
I might well cry if this breaks.
..that leaves
the whole tent anxious.
I remember worrying a bit
about your very large nuts.
LAUGHTER
HE GROANS
Morning, another day. Ah!
I'm so happy to be back
for week two.
I don't wanna flap today.
I'm gonna try and be cool,
controlled and calm.
We'll see how that goes.
Hopefully, this week,
there'll be no more tears.
Well, my mum did say to me,
"Stop crying,
dunno why you're crying."
She's so harsh.
I'm excited about Biscuit Week.
I'm not shaking, I'm all right.
Terrified.
Absolutely terrified.
Biscuits are quite tricky,
so I think it's gonna be
a bit of a difficult week.
As long as I get through,
that's fine.
If I get Star Baker,
that's my final.
Bakers, welcome back
to the tent for Biscuit Week.
And for your Signature Challenge,
the judges would like you each
to make a batch
of 36 chocolate Florentines.
Interesting fact, Florentines were
originally called Florentines.
Thank you, Noel.
I actually wrote that fact.
LAUGHTER
Your Florentines should be
uniform in terms of shape,
texture and flavour, and the judges
will be expecting a perfect snap.
Your Florentines must be dipped,
decorated or coated in chocolate.
You have two hours.
It is time for you to leap
onto your marks, please.
And make sure at that point, then,
that you get set.
For it is now time
to very much... bake!
For chocolate Florentines,
it's all about the snap.
Gotta have a good snap
on a Florentine.
Nervous.
Well, not about eating them, but
about making them, yes, I'm nervous.
It's Biscuit Week, and we're
kicking off with Florentines.
A really good classic Florentine
consists of nuts
and dried fruit bound together
in a caramelly buttery mixture.
I mean, they're fattening,
but they're gorgeous!
This particular challenge is tricky
because they've got to get
the caramel right,
they've got to get the filling
right, choice of chocolate.
I personally think dark chocolate's
the way forward because the
sweetness with the bitterness of the
dark chocolate is a beautiful blend.
BLENDER WHIRS
It would help if I put that bit in.
The perfect Florentine is
neat as a pin and small and thin.
Timing is everything.
Half a minute too long,
and they'll be burnt.
Half a minute too short, and
they won't have that crisp crack.
Morning, Peter. Hello, hello.
So you did really well last week.
What have you got in store for us?
I'm making sticky toffee Florentines
inspired by what is in my
considered opinion the best pudding
in the world, sticky toffee pudding.
So I've got a dark muscovado
sugar in the caramel.
I've got lots of dates so it should
have those lovely toffee flavours.
After pounding the trails
outside his hometown Edinburgh,
proud Scot Peter likes to replace
the lost calories
with some good hearty fare.
Stick in till you stick out. Ah!
Based on his favourite pudding
growing up,
Peter's sticky toffee Florentines
contain a gooey mix of dates,
sultanas
and chopped nuts topped with
caramelised white chocolate.
Will they be thin
and have a snap to them,
or will they will be sticky
and squishy?
Both crunchy and chewy,
cos obviously
when you bite into the dates,
that's gonna be really chewy,
but also I'm hoping that you'll be
able to get a snap from the caramel
nut side of the biscuit as well.
Well, thank you very much,
good luck.
Good luck, Star Baker.
Thank you very much.
Peter's not the only baker inspired
by a childhood favourite.
Traditionally, in Iran,
there's this brittle called sohan,
which is cardamom,
saffron and rose water.
They're flavours that I grew up on.
They're part of my heritage.
When key worker Sura needs to
unwind from a day at the hospital,
she branches out
with a spot of yoga.
Sura's Florentines
containing toasted almonds
and pistachios will be flavoured
with rose water and saffron,
brought back from her trips
to Iran.
Alongside her biscuits, she'll serve
traditional cardamom tea.
How are you?
I'm OK, how are you?
Are you over the old... whoosh?
Yeah, yeah.
Whoosh!
Are you gonna try that again?
No! Oh, look. Whoosh!
Oh, stop it, no, no, no.
That was traumatic.
I saw you in the corner going
like this, "He-he-he!"
And laughing to yourself.
What have you done on your days off?
Practice, practice, practice,
burnt myself out.
Burnt yourself out?
Yeah, I was really tired.
I had a nightmare about Paul.
I had a dream about Paul.
He was just in an apron -
it was pretty powerful.
It was last night, actually.
Stop it!
Good luck, yeah?
You need to go away.
HE LAUGHS
My Florentines are one
of my sister's favourite biscuits.
She had a really,
really sweet tooth when we was kids.
When my mum turned her back, I used
to quickly eat her dinner and...
So she could get
to her pudding quick.
At the end of a hard day's weeding,
green-fingered Linda
and partner Richard love nothing
more than a refreshing
pint in their shed.
I don't normally kiss the barman.
Decorated with delicate
sugar flowers
and dark chocolate, Linda's aiming
to give her childhood-inspired
Florentines a smooth finish.
I blend the nuts down
into quite small chunks.
That way, hopefully,
when they spread,
you get a much more even surface.
But in terms of texture, Linda's
consistency is not for everyone.
In my nuts, I want some bigger bits.
cos you want, obviously,
a bite of nuts.
Mark's career has taken him
around the globe,
but when at home in Liverpool,
he loves nothing more than baking
for friends and wife Laura.
Nice.
Flavoured with cardamom
and decorated with waves
of white chocolate,
Mark's chunky Florentines contain
a mix of macadamia nuts
and dried mango.
We should sell some,
shouldn't we, at lunchtime?
Yeah, we can set up a little shop.
A kiosk.
You make fresh hot biscuits.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I'll get a kiosk on the go.
We'll have it on wheels.
Amazing, wouldn't it? It would
be amazing. Make a mint. Yeah.
We'll make 37 euros each.
I'll have a biscuit, though.
Yeah, feel free. I don't eat them,
I like looking at them.
OK. I eat with my eyes.
That's why I'm not allowed
in restaurants.
But when it comes
to the king of fruits,
Mark has competition.
I know there's a lot of people in
the tent using mango as well today,
so I think it's a bit
of a mango-off.
Three other bakers are also trying
to tempt the judges with this
tropical treat.
It's mango Florentine week,
isn't it?
May the best mango win.
This is dried mango - I'm just gonna
put this in boiling water,
let them soak for a bit,
otherwise it'll just be too chewy.
Ooh! Ooh, juicy! Juicy ones.
Not content with work, baking and
taking care of his extended family,
Mak has also found the time
to write a novel.
First draft finished.
His Florentines feature a trio
of classic Indian ingredients -
mango, cashew and cumin.
But while Mak is familiar
with his flavours,
his hand-piped
peacock feather design
will be a step into the unknown.
I've never decorated them before.
So a world exclusive.
My one's called feathered chocolate
mango Florentines.
I really enjoy eating
all things mango,
so that's why I wanted to put
mango in there.
When not experimenting
with exotic flavours,
Dave and his girlfriend, Stacey,
enjoy walks
with their Japanese hunting dog,
Yoki.
Come on, then, you pain.
He wasn't gonna come back.
He's celebrating his love of mango
with Florentines containing
a mix of nuts
and sesame seeds for added crunch.
He'll decorate each biscuit by
feathering three types of chocolate.
I've weighed out each scoop,
so each scoop is
about 25 or 26 grams
so hopefully they should all come
out nice and uniform.
Whether the bakers use moulds...
I'm using these rings.
..or choose to go freehand,
Paul and Prue will demand
consistency in size and shape...
TIMER BEEPS
..across the batch.
I make my Florentines
the traditional way,
so I've really gotta make sure
that I measure out the biscuit.
This is a cake pop scoop,
to get my quantities right.
Bake Off, supposed to be identical.
I'm being quite precise and weighing
18 grams into each mould.
They want perfection.
They want 36 identical Florentines.
About three quarters of a teaspoon
to a teaspoon in each one.
Some people measure. To be honest,
I haven't got the patience.
I don't want them too chunky
because they won't snap.
I'll be honest,
I haven't made Florentines before.
I'm from Gravesend.
Hobnobs are posh where I'm from.
At home in Kent,
Laura isn't the only baker.
She shares her passion -
and pizza oven - with husband Matt.
Oh, brilliant. Cheers.
A self-confessed salted caramel
addict, Laura will coat her
almond, pecan and raisin Florentines
in sweet milk chocolate.
Because it's quite salty,
dark chocolate was too rich
so I chose milk chocolate as a base.
My family, when I've made these,
have just absolutely devoured them.
Lottie has also decided to go
with a family favourite.
I am making quarantine Florentines.
For my grandparents, because
it is their favourite biscuit.
Nana and papa?
Although Lottie's grandparents live
just down the road from her
in Littlehampton,
it's been six months
since she's been able to give them
a hug.
I love you. I love you too.
I love you too.
I'll Facetime you later.
Her grandparents' favourite
Florentines are a classic
combination of chopped nuts,
ginger and sour cherries,
but when it comes to decoration,
Lottie's taking
an abstract approach.
If you're doing
Jackson Pollock-esque splashes,
will they all be uniform?
LAUGHS: No. Absolutely not.
That's the reason I'm doing
Jackson Pollock splashes.
A uniform mess.
Uniform mess - exactly, Paul.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Right.
Your lives.
How's it going?
Right...
In they go.
Because they contain
so much sugar,
judging the bake time
of their Florentines
will test the bakers
to their limit.
Those are going in
at 180 for seven minutes.
These are going in
for about 12 minutes.
11 minutes on the top shelf
and 11 and a half minutes
on the bottom shelf.
I have to be really careful
about the timing of these,
cos they can go over
really quickly.
12 and a half minutes.
Actually,
12 minutes and 26 seconds.
I don't really do precision,
but I realise
it's definitely called for.
While most of the bakers have their
first batch of biscuits baking...
I'm sorry, but I'm panicking.
..Hermine is still moulding hers.
I'm a little bit behind.
Born and raised in West Africa
on her mother's pineapple farm,
Hermine moved to London
almost 20 years ago
and is studying to become
an accountant.
I've done enough for today,
I need a break.
She's adding shredded dried mango
and coconut flakes
to her Florentines
which she'll coat in ruby chocolate
and decorate
with spray-painted trees.
I'm worried about getting the snap
cos, to be honest,
uh, mine were quite chewy.
Apparently, Paul Hollywood
likes them with the snap,
so, yeah, bit nervous about that.
Perfecting a batch of 36
identical biscuits will require
the bakers to walk a time
and temperature tightrope.
In practice, I took 'em
out the oven too soon,
so just trying to wait
for that golden colour.
I'm not quite sure
when they're going to be done.
Are they done, are they not?
It's just a hard one to call.
Gotta get that snap.
Misjudge either...
Right, let's see how they look.
..and any chance of achieving
uniform texture and colour...
Whoa... will go up in smoke.
I'm not happy with them.
They're just not as brown as I
thought they would be at this stage.
The bottom ones just need
a minute longer.
CRUNCH!
That sounded crunchy, didn't it?
I've cooked them
for a little bit longer today, which
I think's given me good snap.
I'm 90% sure they've got a snap.
Second batch in.
They're just great -
I'm happy with them.
I'm thinking, are they even?
Is that round?
What's Paul Hollywood gonna say?
They seem rather gooey, actually.
So my Florentines, they're inspired
by grandmother
who had a very lovely garden
and was a very good homely cook.
Very beautiful.
A keen gardener himself
when he's not pruning,
Rowan can be found
bringing out the shine
on his large collection of antiques.
That's a bit better.
In homage
to his grandmother's garden,
Rowan's colourful Florentines
feature a trio
of vibrant dried fruits.
But when it comes to decoration,
he's had to look no further
than his own flamboyant wardrobe.
I'm coating them
with modelling chocolate waistcoats.
Which is in honour
of your waistcoat collection.
It is, with my garden on the back.
Yes. Ah, lovely.
How many waistcoats have you got?
Uh, I think I've got about a dozen
or so.
I've got an 18th century one,
embroidered in France in about 1780,
which is beautiful.
Paul, this is what posh people
talk about, isn't it?
This is going right over my head.
With their biscuits cooling,
the bakers can turn their attention
to chocolate.
Gotta love the smell of chocolate.
I'm topping my Florentines
with caramelised white chocolate.
You bake it in the oven,
but then it takes on a really dark
caramelly colour and flavour,
and it tastes so, so good.
I'm just melting some chocolate,
and I'm tempering.
Tempering gives it that snap.
It's a really frustrating process,
especially for white chocolate
and it's very precise.
Just keep stirring this,
cos it's really hot still.
A couple of degrees out and you have
to start the whole process again.
That looks delicious.
I'd sort of like to get in that.
I know, I think I could stick
my head in a bucket of that.
If I was an insect, I'd get
in that like a sort of hot tub.
But with her Florentines
only just out of the oven...
..Hermine is playing catch up.
Stabbing the Florentines.
Please!
It's, uh, ruby chocolate,
and I only discovered it
a few months ago.
And I was really surprised
about the flavour.
Almost like white chocolate,
but then you've got this lovely
sourness coming through at the end.
Now a sculptor, Marc spent
many years working as a landscape
photographer, a passion he now
shares with youngest daughter Rosie.
Brilliant.
Not only is Marc using
ruby chocolate to
give his Florentines extra flavour,
but he's adding ginger to give
his square-shaped biscuits a kick.
What do you think of the square
shape? It's nice, isn't it?
I like the square shape.
I've never, ever seen
a square before,
so I'm very exc... very excited
about these biscuits.
It's a completely new concept.
Yeah, cos I don't...
I, I'm, I'm learning shapes.
You know rhombus now, don't you?
I know rhombus... Cuboid?
Dodecahedron. I don't know cuboid.
You do know circle.
But I don't know semicircles. No.
I'm not onto them yet.
We'll do that later.
We'll learn it later.
Sweet, lovely bakers, you do be
having 30 of minutes remainings.
Yes!
How marvellous. Pff!
Oh, I'm melting chocolate -
no time to think.
I put some colour in this chocolate.
It's just gone a bit solid,
so I'm gonna reheat them.
I'm just slightly short of time.
Lots of little waistcoats.
There's a huge amount of work to do.
I'm always very ambitious.
I'm just going
for the standard dunk.
Dunk and wipe.
A dip, a swipe and trying to make
them as neat as possible.
What I'm aiming to do is just get
a really thin layer on here,
sit the biscuits on,
and then the chocolate's gonna set
beautifully so that they don't give
me any stress whatsoever.
RATTLING
Oh, gosh.
It's going well, isn't it?
SHE LAUGHS
RAPS: Bakers, you've got
15 minutes left.
You see, if you communicate
through rap... Right.
..the kids really take it in.
They take it in better. Yeah.
Let's get them decorated.
I like to make flowers.
It's very therapeutic.
And I strive to get them
as fine as I can
so that they look real.
Look at these! Ooh!
I like foods that are pink,
apart from taramasalata.
How's it all going?
Uh, not too well. I don't know
if they'll set in time.
Not bad.
I went to art school for this.
Slightly tight, to be quite honest.
Speed is of the essence.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have... one minute left.
I'm trying to hide the worst ones
at the bottom.
They look identical. Very happy.
It would've been nice to have
finished rather more of them.
What a disaster.
Do you want me to count check?
Yeah, yeah, could you?
You need one more.
One, two, three, four, five.
So it's 36, isn't it?
35, 36. I've got 37 - I'll eat one.
Bakers, your time is up.
Step away from your chocolat
Florentines.
Get them on your plate quick!
Mak. Sorry.
Ooph!
Wow.
Looks good, looks good.
Ooph!
Oh, mine didn't go well.
No? They look good, though.
The bakers' Florentines will now be
judged by Prue and Paul.
Hello, Dave. Hello.
It's like a Magic Eye poster!
THEY CHUCKLE
It's cos of my jumper, I thought
I was back on the rave scene.
I think you've done pretty well
with the feathering.
Three colours is... quite difficult.
Good snap. Massive snap.
You've got the snap,
the flavour's good.
You can taste the nut and mango,
it all sort of works.
Sesame seed as well, which I love.
I just think you need more
texture in there as well. Yeah.
I love the dark chocolate.
It's a nice biscuit. Thank you.
Good.
It looks a little bit lumpy.
TOO lumpy.
Yes, I remember worrying
a bit about your very large nuts.
Mainly because...
Oh...
Right...
It snaps, though.
The white chocolate is quite
dominant.
It needed something else -
maybe a bit more fruit in there.
Could be better. OK. Thank you.
That's a pretty classic Florentine.
Yeah.
Snaps quite well.
I love that for flavours. Yes!
Um, I think the issue is
you want something bitter.
If you'd just kept it to dark
chocolate underneath,
you would've been on a winner.
But otherwise, that's a great
Florentine. Thank you.
Great, thank you.
Well done! Thanks.
Have you practised these?
Yes. Have you done them in the time?
No. Right. Do you remember
what we said last week?
Entirely. So my question is,
why did you do it?
"Course I have!"
Because I like them.
Anyway, it certainly does not snap.
No. I love the flavours of it.
It's not baked enough.
The idea of the waistcoats, I love,
but honestly, that modelling
chocolate ruins the biscuit.
Oh, OK. Oh, all right.
It's so sweet.
Great flavours. Again, simplify
things to get it done in time.
He's a dreamer. Don't stop dreaming.
But thank you anyway.
They look so sweet -
like little boats.
Looks amazing.
Mmm!
The crunch from the nuts
is gorgeous.
You do get a little bit
of saffron in there as well.
You've created a beautiful,
well-balanced Florentine.
It's lovely.
The only problem is, we asked for
a...
Snap. Snap. Yeah.
And what's the tea?
Cardamom tea.
That's delicious as well.
It's lovely, isn't it?
Can I take it with me?
Thank you so much, thank you.
You've got the colour
of a... a sticky toffee pudding.
Yeah. Smells like one too.
Ooh, bit of a bend.
The flavour's delicious.
I've never had anything like it.
Particularly like
that white chocolate.
I LOVE that caramel flavour. Peter,
you're very clever with your ideas.
You've come up with something
that is truly unique.
Mm. Thank you. That was a touching
moment, wasn't it?
That smells delicious.
But as we all know,
eating's cheating - so, no.
They're a little bit scruffy.
Time wasn't on my side.
Hmm...
They needed slightly longer
in the oven.
There's something really tough
in there.
Is it the mango? Probably, yes.
Hmm. It's like leather.
Oh, God, this is agonising.
The mango needs to be soaked
cos it is just too chewy.
Love the flavour of it, though.
Thank you.
It's very pretty,
and neat as anything.
Unique,
unusual to use the ruby chocolate.
Yeah.
And I do like the uniformity of it.
Thank you. It isn't
going to snap, though. Yeah.
Ruby chocolate's quite tart
and it blends really well with
the ginger, so overall you've got
a really nice flavour.
I love the sour cherries.
Very surprising,
very original and very delicious.
Brilliant, I'll take that.
Well done. Well done.
Thank you. Well done.
I think you've lost...
..in the appearance
what a Florentine is. Mm.
You should be able to see
much more texture,
and you're not getting that -
it's as flat as a pancake.
Well, I bet it tastes nice.
And it has a snap. Ginger's coming
through quite strong, which I like.
It's like having
a ginger brandy snap.
It's a delicious biscuit,
but it is not a Florentine.
OK. Thank you, Linda. Thank you.
What's the decoration?
Supposed to be, uh,
a sort of a peacock effect.
A peacock? I thought
it was a tennis racquet!
Uh, it's to celebrate Wimbledon!
Yes, it was.
THEY CHUCKLE
They're quite gooey.
Probably could've stayed in there
another four, five minutes.
You soaked your mango, didn't you?
Yeah. But I imagine that would've
contributed
to its sort of sogginess. I like the
flavour, but it's not a Florentine.
Never mind. Thank you, Mak.
Thank you. Thank you.
Well, I have to say, I think
they look rather good. Thank you.
I think you've got a good
tempered chocolate on there
and I do like the top - classic
Florentine. You've got a nice shine,
it's busy, and that's what
a Florentine should look like.
Bit of a snap.
It's chocolatey, it's nutty,
love the sour cherry.
It's delicious.
The ginger and the cherry with the
dark chocolate is just fantastic and
it does snap, it's nice and thin.
I can't find a fault with them,
really.
SHE GASPS
Well done. Thank you!
I'll take that one with me.
Thank you.
What?! As if!
Completely mad.
Imagine, me!
Never going to wash my hand again.
I mean, I like my fruit chunky,
but what am I meant to say?
You know, they're the experts -
if they're not right, then they're
not right. I'm just disappointed.
I think that went really well.
I did get a snap.
That's what I was going for,
the snap. The concept was good,
but a bit too ambitious. I shall
endeavour to take the advice.
It could've gone better. I've just
got to stay... stay calm,
just put this morning behind me
and, you know, look forward
to this afternoon.
MATT: The bakers were able to
practise their signature bakes,
but have no idea what
Technical mystery lies ahead.
Bakers, it's time for your Technical
Challenge which, today, has been
set by Prue.
Prue, any words of advice?
This is a classic, so read
your recipe - no going off piste.
As ever, your Technical Challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're going to have to ask
the judges to leave the tent.
Off you pop.
Let's say things about them
while they're gone.
Prue would like you to make
12 hand-shaped
coconut macaroons.
Six of them must be drizzled
and filled with chocolate
and six of them must be piped
with a delicious mango curd.
Oh, sounds quite involved.
If I were you, I'd just go out
and buy some. Much easier.
It doesn't work like that. Oh.
They must be crispy and golden
on the outside, but chewy on the
inside.
You've got an hour and 45 minutes.
On your marks. Get set.
Go to the shops. Or bake. Or bake.
Oh, Jesus.
Macaroons? I've got no idea, mate.
I don't think I've even eaten one,
let alone made one. This is going
to be really interesting.
I don't think I've even eaten one,
I'm familiar with macaroons,
and I've made them once,
a very long time ago.
But not filled.
I've made these, uh,
with my mum before.
But donkeys ago.
Haven't had macaroons for years!
They're all right, but they get
stuck between your teeth.
So, Prue, macaroons as a Technical
Challenge, good choice!
Bit of a favourite of mine.
I know, I love them too.
They always look so simple,
and if you read the recipe it's,
"Oh, there's no problem with that!"
But I think they're trickier
than they sound.
It's really important to get
the mixture right.
We've given them
coconut flakes, which they need
to put in a processor briefly.
If they overdo it, they won't get
this nice, rough edge - they'll
get a smooth paste which will stick
together
and won't be nearly so pleasant.
And I think these look beautiful.
They're all the same size,
regardless
whether they're mango or chocolate.
I think I'll try the mango one
first.
So as soon as you bite into it,
instantly there's coconut.
The mango is beautiful as well.
It's just the right consistency.
Smooth as anything, but it's set.
It's not running.
You have to pipe a wall round
the edge, and if you don't get
the high enough walls,
you don't get enough mango curd.
OK, moving on to the chocolate one.
Very neat on the lines on the top.
And a good decent lump of chocolate
in there, isn't there?
Hmm, hmm. It's gorgeous blended
with the coconut, you're right.
We've squeezed them a little bit
on time to get this done -
I mean, it is a challenge.
The most important thing is timing
in the oven
because they need to be just
golden-brown,
crunchy on the outside,
slightly chewy and sticky
in the middle.
The test is the colour.
Take it out when it looks like that.
I think there's nothing better.
It takes me back
to when I was a kid again.
Perfect with a great cup of tea.
First instruction -
make the mango curd.
I think it's a little bit mean.
Trying to refresh my memory
of how to make a curd.
So you've got mango puree in there,
caster sugar,
you've got one egg and two yolks.
Bit of lime juice
and a bit of unsalted butter.
And then very carefully cook it
over the gentle heat.
What I don't want is scrambled egg,
mango-flavoured scrambled egg.
Cos curd can take a little while
to thicken up.
Smells nice anyway.
Have you made macaroons before?
No, I've made macarons before,
but not macaroons.
They're a different food. Yes.
They've added an extra letter
and called it macaroons.
They have. Next year, people will
have to make macarooons
cos they're going to add
another letter to it.
My curd is starting to thicken.
It should be quite droopy,
but quite thick.
It's very important
that I do well in this challenge
so that's why I'm going to be
extra careful.
I think that's looking OK.
Let's add the butter.
If you add the cold butter
and then just keep whisking it in,
it should go really nice and silky
and smooth - I think.
Either that,
or I'm just talking out my arse.
Oh, yeah, it's thickening nicely
now. That doesn't look too bad.
Mango curd has to chill.
Keep it chilled.
I'm trying to just cool it quickly
by putting it in the freezer.
My mango curd is in the fridge.
So, "Using the round cutter as a
guide, draw 12 circles on
"the rice paper
and then cut out the circles."
Is this rice paper? That rice paper
does look delicious, doesn't it?
I never tried that.
You can - yes, it's edibubble.
So far, so good -
I'm good at drawing circles.
I'm just waiting for my curd
to thicken a bit more.
It's still a little bit runny
and so I really need to crack on
with everything else.
Glasses on. I mean business.
Why is that? Hand shake?
Come on, spill the dirt.
How did it feel when Hollywood...
..his big sausagey fingers
gripped your pale...
Yeah... ET-like fingers?
Thanks, yeah.
How did it feel? I felt nothing.
Angry? I just felt very shocked.
You felt nothing?! And like...
Cold, dead inside.
No, I'm not dead inside - I just
went numb, I didn't know what
was happening.
That's it, that's the pivotal moment
in your baking career.
Yeah, that's it.
I've peaked, for sure.
"For the macaroons, tip the shredded
coconut into the food processor
"and blitz until the flakes
are small enough to pipe."
It's been very clear in the recipe
to not over-blitz the coconut,
so trying to listen to that.
I think... Do you know? That'll do.
It's hard not to lose your nerve
when you look around,
and everyone else is miles ahead.
But I just was really worried
about leaving this curd for too
long, you know?
I'm going to go with that.
"Add the almond extract, rice flour,
condensed milk, and pulse."
This is condensed milk.
Nice and sticky. I love this.
Could you drink that?
Oh, I've had it.
What, you've just drunk condensed
milk? Yeah, I have.
Really?! I love it.
I leave you in disgust.
"Carefully fold whisked egg whites
into the coconut mixture."
It's just going to help raise
and keep them light.
So I guess it'll be kind
of like a meringuey, chewy texture.
Now... I think that is done.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
So basically you have 52½
minutes left.
I'm running behind.
So at the minute, I'm just adding
the coconut. I think there was
time in the recipe
to make the curd properly
so I hope
that I haven't just wasted that!
"Spoon half of the mixture
into a piping bag fitted with
"a large STAR nozzle."
The mixture looks all right.
Looks yummy. I kind of want to
just eat the batter as it is.
Hmm, I'd quite like a bit of rum
in there, I think, but... overall,
mmm, it's nice.
"Pipe a ring of coconut
around the edge of the rice paper
"and pipe a small
amount of mixture into the hole."
So you're making a little dish,
really, for the curd.
I'm worried about how deep the hole
has to be in order to fit
a filling in.
It's quite pipeable,
so it's holding its shape.
Come on, Laura, you know how to
pipe. I feel like mine's too thick.
I wonder whether I haven't made it
quite fine enough.
"For the remaining six macaroons,
place a spoonful of coconut
"mixture on the remaining discs,
and flatten."
"Place a square of chocolate into
the centre of each coconut circle."
Then I'm going to place
a spoon of the mixture over the top
and create a dome.
If you don't get that chocolate
covered up, it's going to start
running all out of it as it's
cooking, so I'm just trying to
make sure that it's all covered in
now.
I'm just trying to get them
as even as I possibly can.
Save some time now.
On the recipe, it tells us to bake.
Er, so...
Useful.
Going to pop those in the oven now.
I genuinely have no idea on timing.
It's on 130.
Gonna start with ten minutes.
Starting off with ten minutes,
and then I'll check them,
see how long they go.
With how much time's left, it's
an indication that it's probably
a longer bake
than what everyone reckons.
I reckon 25 minutes in the end.
OK, they've gone in.
30 minutes.
It's a low and slow cook.
I do feel a little bit
up against it.
These are probably going to take
20 minutes to bake as well,
so it just doesn't give me
an awful lot of time.
My curd better be good.
QUIETLY: Bakers,
you've got half an hour left.
Don't want to wake Matt up.
Half an hour.
Come on!
It's taking so long!
They're not even toasty.
They did say that they wanted
a nice golden top.
Mine aren't golden.
I don't know, man. What is golden -
do you know what I mean?
Golden can mean anything, really.
I just don't know.
These are not going to get
golden-brown, I don't think.
Lordy, Lordy, Lordy.
It's really intense, innit?
I find it strangely relaxing.
Do you? What, just
watching everyone else stress?
Seeing their dreams slide away.
Oh, God. I don't have any patience.
Certainly not looking golden.
But I think it'll take a really,
really long time to get golden.
What do you reckon? Least another
five more minutes, I think.
They're taking ages, actually.
Yeah, they are, aren't they?
A lot longer than
I was expecting them to cook. Mmm.
I think I shouldn't have
come down here - I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to get back up.
That's what I think.
Ooh, my Lord!
No, I'm all right. Might go in
with those. Let's have a look.
I think maybe one minute longer.
These are looking rustic, but not
too bad. I've got to get them cool.
I might pull mine, you know.
So I'm going to get them out now.
They're nice and golden.
Think I'm happy.
I don't know what they're
supposed to look like,
but I think they look all right.
Ooh, they look good!
Now, these ones are quite a lot
larger than those ones.
They are. Was that intentional?
Well... no.
Right. You should've said yes.
Oh, we'll do it again.
So these ones are a little bit
larger than those ones,
is that intentional? Yes, they've
got chocolate inside.
Right. That's a good approach.
MATT CHUCKLES
I think the colour's looking good,
but I just don't think
they're ready yet.
I think I'm at 28 minutes now.
I reckon a couple more minutes.
Yeah, just need five more minutes,
I'll be done.
Maybe they ARE ready.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes
until we tell you
that you have ten minutes.
Matt! You have 15 minutes.
That was mean!
I'm bad.
Gonna give them a little bit longer.
What am I supposed to put in this?
"Spoon a small amount of set curd
into the centre of each ring."
OK, set curd.
That's the sort of consistency
I would have
if I was making a lemon curd.
They're finally coming out.
Ow, ow, ow!
Dave's look rather sophisticated.
Yeah, I like them.
Does look as if the cat's had
a bit of an accident.
"To decorate the chocolate maroons,
pipe fine lines across them
"with melted chocolate."
That's what I'm going for,
nice and neat.
Oh, THAT'S more like it!
Bit more freestyle.
Just putting the mango curd
in the middle.
Ideally, I would want them
to be cool.
Cos I'm conscious
that I'm quite behind.
Bakers, it's basically too late now.
You've got one minute left.
Chocolate's seizing...
It's totally seized on me.
Have mine. Cheers,
you've totally saved me there.
There's not enough space
for all six.
Bakers, your time is up.
Well, I think they're beautiful.
You can see the influence
of fine French patisserie.
Please bring your trays forward
to the front
and put them behind your photograph.
Sura, hang back a little bit.
I'm joking.
Prue and Paul are looking
for 12 uniform coconut macaroons,
six filled with mango curd
and six filled with chocolate,
crispy on the outside
and chewy in the middle.
So let's have a
look at the first one.
I like things to be the same when
you're looking at the sizes. Yeah.
They do look very similar.
They maybe could've done
with a little bit longer.
It's delicious, but not quite crisp
enough on the outside
and a bit too squashy.
Mm. Let's just have a check
of that mango.
It's not bad. I'd like to see more
of a ridge around there to create...
A well... a little pond in
the middle, yeah.
Let's move on to the second one,
shall we?
The chocolate ones look
a bit untidy.
And they're different sizes.
I mean, that one's much smaller than
that one. Yeah.
Needed a little bit longer
those, actually.
Now, I like this sort of decoration,
the lines.
They're very different sizes.
These ones are tiny
and these ones are big.
Well, it does taste very good.
Moving on, slightly underbaked.
The piping's a little peculiar.
It is odd, isn't it?
That one's a sort of squirt.
Hm, it's too soft.
The coconut that's underneath
the mango
is almost like it went
into the oven. Yeah.
But moving on, I like this one
cos you've got
a nice bit of caramelisation
as well from the coconut. Yeah.
There you go.
It's delicious.
Crispy on the outside
and soft in the middle.
Mango's tasty as well. OK, moving
on. Right.
I quite like these as well.
They're uniform,
they're all the same size.
Nice browning effect. Decent amount
of curd. Yeah.
That's got a good flavour.
Hm, curd's nice too.
It's a little liquid.
And moving on.
They're equal, bit small
and a bit undercooked as well.
Yeah, definitely underbaked.
It's lovely with the mango,
just needed longer in the oven.
These are very neat.
I love these lines like that.
It's well baked, that one, as well.
That's got lovely flavour.
The curd is perfect.
It cuts, it doesn't just
flow. It's a really good one.
This, again, is quite a decent one.
However, they over-blitzed
the mixture.
Quite smooth.
It's good. Hm.
Again, this one's well baked.
Could do more of a wall.
They're a little bit hard.
And quite chewy. Yeah.
Moving on to the last one.
Neat, tidy, but underbaked.
But it's the colour - you can see
how pale that is.
Yeah, that's going to be
really squashy.
It's a shame cos that's neat,
that. Hm.
Prue and Paul will now rank
the coconut macaroons
from worst to best.
In 11th place...
..is this one.
Rowan, bit underbaked,
not very good piping,
little uneven.
And in tenth position
we have this one.
Whose is this?
Down to colour only, Peter.
In ninth place is this one.
This is a really common problem
of not baking it quite long enough.
In eighth we have this one.
Whose is this?
They were very, very small
and you needed a little bit
longer in the oven.
Laura's seventh, Sura's sixth,
Hermine's fifth and Linda's fourth.
And in third place is this one.
Who's that?
Mak, these were absolutely
excellent.
Thank you.
In second we have this one.
Loads of texture, nice chocolate
on the top, spot on.
Which leaves...
..this one.
Dave, really excellent macaroons -
curd nice, even, perfect.
Thank you.
Came first in technical.
What an improvement from ninth
last week.
It makes me feel more confident
going into tomorrow.
Spring in the step
for the morning, yeah.
I mean, it's a bit of a fall from
grace after this morning, isn't it?
And now I'm just
terrified for tomorrow.
I can't believe
what just happened, second.
I was chaotic. I was running behind
everyone else,
so I'm delighted.
It wasn't my best moment.
They did slightly
look like the cat's lavatory.
I'm feeling much better after
that. I think I've clawed a bit back
from this morning,
so it just gives me hope
for tomorrow.
There's just the Showstopper
challenge left
before Prue and Paul decide
who will be leaving the tent
and who's destined for star baker.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your
Showstopper challenge.
Today, the judges would like you to
make a 3D biscuit table setting
from a memorable meal
you once had.
They want you to sculpt
your biscuit dough
to make highly decorative
and realistic-looking biscuits that
deceive the eye into thinking
they're teapots or cups or knives,
etc, you get my drift.
You can use any type of biscuits,
any flavours you want,
but, remember, this is a Showstopper
so it can't just look good -
it has to taste fantastic.
You have 100,000 hours.
Four. 400,000 hours.
Just four hours.
Just four, you'll never make it.
On your marks... Get set.
Bake!
I'm feeling really good.
Just got to keep my cool.
I'm pumping, yeah.
Yeah, I'm feeling relaxed.
I'm just going to enjoy it,
you know.
I have so much to do
and I am absolutely bricking it.
It's the Showstopper and we're
asking the bakers to complete
a dinner set, but it must be
moulded.
Rather than having straight
biscuits,
I'd like to see something
that shows
they're utilising their biscuit to
shape round something,
to mould, to sculpt.
We want the bakers to use
their dough as a clay
to get this balance between
beautiful objects
and delicious biscuits.
The big issue the bakers are going
to have is almost
the volume of biscuit needed
to create the set.
It's bulk, batch baking.
It's not going to be easy.
Rowan, how are you doing?
Are you all right?
Hello. So far, so good.
Right, table setting - what are you
doing?
Table setting. I am doing
a 90th birthday breakfast tray
for my great-aunt,
so the chocolate pot is
in the form of a lighthouse. Right.
Hopefully, with a flashing
light on top,
and then, there are a couple
of shell, uh, little, little plates.
Rowan's aiming high again with
a maritime masterpiece
he's hoping will keep him
clear of disaster.
His lemon biscuit lighthouse hot
chocolate pot will be adorned
with Viennese biscuit sea creatures.
Have you practised this?
I have.
And have you done it in the time?
No.
Brilliant.
You WILL finish this challenge, OK?
In four hours. I want to see
what you can do.
And that's what's so frustrating.
I know.
Do you understand?
I know. I'll do my very best.
I'm just adding my spices.
I'm going to just put an extra
little bit in for good luck. Ha-ha!
To create a Showstopper
that will wow the judges...
This is extra brute cocoa powder,
gives it more of a richer
chocolate taste.
..not only must their biscuits be
packed with flavour...
So there's 20 tablespoons of coffee.
Keep me going till lunchtime.
..it's vital they're strong enough
to hold their shape.
Whenever someone says a moulded
biscuit
or a structure with biscuit,
everyone instantly jumps to
gingerbread,
so it's going to be tough to
stand out in the crowd today.
Peter's aiming to grab the judges'
attention
with a gingerbread haggis filled
with Scottish raspberry
and oat cranachan cream.
It is Scotland on a plate.
Scotland as a plate.
Mark's taken his inspiration
from much further afield.
My table setting is an Ethiopian
coffee ceremony.
Yeah, I love it, every time
I'm in Ethiopia,
I have quite a lot of coffee, yeah,
I love coffee, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Decorated with striking geometric
icing,
Mark's ceremonial coffee set
will be made of a cinnamon
and coffee dough, darkened with
edible charcoal powder.
This is where it gets messy.
And this, this recipe
suits me quite well
because I am a messy baker
so it feels quite nice to get
stuck into something.
But he's not the only baker
opting for a dark dough.
I am making a Viking table setting.
Vikings are just so cool,
they're just so badass.
Lottie's creating a charcoal
and gingerbread dining set
fit for Valhalla -
the great hall in Norse mythology
where heroes slain in battle are
welcomed into the afterlife.
Are you a Viking,
are you from Viking...? Secretly.
No. No? I'm really not.
I'm 98% British.
It's very upsetting and boring.
If you mess this up, you won't
get into Valhalla, you know that?
And that's what worries me the most.
Well, let's see if we can open
the gates of Valhalla later, then.
The shaping is really
important in this.
It needs to look realistic
and not like
a five-year-old's done it,
which, I'm not going to lie,
is a kind of a challenge.
Sculpting biscuit dough will not
only test the bakers' creativity...
This is the thing that stresses me
out the most.
..but will push their technical
know-how to the limit.
So all these are just going to
stay in its mould,
and then, hopefully,
when it's baked,
it should release straight away.
Not only is it tricky to shape,
but can easily become tough
if overworked.
This is the lighthouse
so I have found,
if you foil it first,
it'll hopefully hold it all
together.
This definitely goes
way beyond baking knowledge
and takes you into the realms of
how to be a potter.
While most bakers are shaping,
then baking,
Mak is taking a unique approach.
I'm not going to be using moulds.
So that's interesting.
So, instead of moulding your
biscuit,
you are making all the pieces flat
so they'll be like hexagonal.
Well, square-shaped.
Mak's using flat-pack to create
an Art Deco-style chai tea set
with oblong tea pot and cuboid cups.
How have you got on in practice?
To be quite honest with you,
I have struggled.
That's why I've actually pared
it down somewhat
in the final bake.
Well, it's better to do something
which you can achieve.
That's right, yes.
In contrast, Dave's aiming to
conjure up some magical curves.
An Aladdin's saucer.
So they're going to look very
similar to that.
If I rub them,
I'd wish for star baker.
Taking his inspiration from a trip
to Mexico,
Dave's coffee jugs will be part of
a chocolate and coffee flavour table
setting,
decorated with the colours
of the Mexican flag.
Got to have the flavour there,
but high detail, I think,
what they're after as well,
so, if I keep my cool,
should be good.
We are actually going in.
Getting the larger pieces
into the oven
as quickly as possible is vital...
One down, two to go.
..to give the bakers time to prepare
the multitude of smaller
biscuit bakes.
This is the brandy snap.
Looks super healthy, doesn't it?
I've got this embossing mat.
It just gives a really lovely lacy
detail to the biscuit.
Just lift it up
and gently place it in the middle.
Try to keep it as neat as you can.
This is the amaretti biscuit.
Want it to look like a woven
sort of, uh, place mat.
These are delicious biscuits.
They've got cinnamon, nutmeg,
ginger
and black pepper,
so they are amazing.
Sura's Ramadan tea set will be
made from
a Dutch-style speculaas biscuit,
each piece elaborately decorated
with intricate patterns.
During Ramadan,
we always have people over.
You break your fast, after that,
you sit down for tea
and that's what it's
based around - that social vibe.
However, favouring a more solitary
dining experience is Marc.
This is the mug,
knife and spoon and plate.
Just a basic breakfast
tea set for one.
Marc will use his experience
as a sculptor
to fashion
his spiced ginger biscuit set,
complete with toast rack and toast.
I've worked with woods
and metals for most of my life.
It's a bit different
making something out of biscuit.
Right. Press on.
Are they ready to come now?
Yeah, they're looking good.
Got to keep my eye on stuff, lots of
different things going on at once.
This is my haggis biscuit.
It's still a bit bumpy, but it is
a sheep's stomach after all.
How does it look?
Rustic, rustic's all right.
Before it cools down complete,
I need to make my shapes.
They're looking OK, I think, yeah,
as long as it keeps going OK,
I'll be all right.
I'm happy with them.
I'll be decorating it
in some colourful icing.
Colourful icing? That was vague...
Yeah... which is good.
Then, if you don't get it all done,
you'll say, "Well, I was only
supposed to do one blob there,
"a nipple there and a nipple there."
Exactly. They are like breasts.
They are, aren't they?
There's no denying that.
Just going to get the next
things in now.
To create all the elements for their
complex biscuit constructions...
Right, going in.
..the bakers must manage
numerous batches...
That's the trencher
that my haggis is going to sit on.
..if they are to stand any chance
of finishing on time.
They've come out nice.
You've got to be so careful
because they split very, very
easily.
It's a very, very delicate biscuit.
Inspired by a high tea
she once had in Amsterdam,
Linda's one of the few bakers
swerving sturdy gingerbread,
gambling instead on a delicate
rose water shortbread.
Everything you make is going to be
out of this very fragile
short biscuit.
Oh, OK. I think that's quite brave.
It is very brave.
It's Bake Off,
you've got to be brave.
Yeah, absolutely.
Go for it.
Oh, God, I've got to unmould it.
I just need to ease
it into the plate.
I don't want to be giving them
a flat disc.
The bakers now face
the critical task
of separating the delicate biscuit
from the mould.
If this does break, I can stick it
back together badly
with caramel, but I don't have time
to faff about with it.
They only get one chance.
I just want to get this out.
If the biscuits shatter,
so will their Showstopper dreams.
Collateral damage.
That's why I made extras.
I might well cry if this breaks.
Oh, for goodness' sake.
Oh, no!
Broken there slightly.
This is very delicate.
Hardly dare breathe.
Oh.
I may have just overbaked it
by a minute or so.
There's no way this is happening.
Bakers, you have 200,000 hours left.
Time is ticking.
Two hours, bakers.
You're halfway through.
200,000 hours.
Can't believe that we've been
two hours already.
I'm going to let that cool.
It has a bit of a shape to it.
Oh, thank BLEEP.
Let's get this tuile out.
That looks done to me.
I just want to put it somewhere safe
now I've made the thing.
That's my Amaretti place mat.
As it cools, that'll go really nice
and crunchy.
These are done. Perfection actually.
See how they've cracked at the top?
Happy with that.
Almost good enough to eat.
It's my last one going in.
I had hoped to be finished
all my baking by now,
but I've still got a couple of
things to finish.
I'm terrified, to be honest with
you,
because I've completely lost
track of what I'm doing.
All I know is that I've got
half a boat there.
Yeah, I've got so much to do.
I'm in a good place right now,
I think.
I'm making a three-tier cake stand
and I'm trying to replicate an
afternoon tea
that I had for my lovely
nan's 80th birthday.
Keen to do justice to the family
celebration, Laura's gingerbread
and brandy snap bake comes with
an extra sprinkle of commitment.
I've probably practised 15 times
in total.
I've changed the recipe,
I've changed the design.
I just really hope it tastes nice.
But Laura's got stiff competition
when it comes to tea time.
Sugar lace, I'm going to use for my
tea canister.
It's a show stopper so one needs to
be ambitious.
Hermine's creating a Japanese-style
tea set also in gingerbread,
adorned with hand-painted flowers
and cherry blossom.
Hermine said earlier she enjoys my,
er, comedy shows.
Do you enjoy Noel's comedy shows or
are you not quite sure who he is?
I didn't know Noel did comedy.
Ooh!
Well, I'm being honest!
Noel is one of Britain's most
popular children's entertainers.
This is my last bit.
That's my baking done.
Turning the oven off, that feels
really, really great.
As their biscuits cool, the bakers
can turn their attention to
decorations.
So I'm just prepping up
the egg glaze now,
so it will give that terracotta
look, yeah.
I've made my own fondant
out of marshmallows.
I don't normally say this,
but I think that is spot on.
In here, I've got some oatmeal,
whipped cream, raspberries,
honey, whisky and that's going to
be my cranachan cream filling.
It's good.
I'm making a really soft-set jam.
I want it to look like blood.
Um, bit dark.
How long have we got left?
Bakers!
ECHOES: Bakers, bakers!
You... You, you...
..have... have, have...
..one... one, one...
..hour... hour, hour...
..left, left, left, left, left.
Very echoey in here, isn't it?
That's my basic tea pot.
So if somebody can just hold
it like that all the way through.
This is the glue that's going to
glue everything together.
I think the bakers this
year are very, very talented,
but, actually, I think it's quite a
tricky challenge.
It is. What I like is the theme.
We've got a Ramadan tea
and we've got a Valhalla Viking.
If it sticks, great.
Ugh!
Ethiopian.
Ethiopian one.
I hope they don't say
they can't taste the coffee.
Viennese lighthouse.
Slightly ragged at the bottom,
but I'll trim it afterwards.
They are very imaginative.
It's nice, isn't it?
I made a spoon.
No spoons today.
A lot rides on this for a few
people.
I'd like to see them all finish on
time.
I'm currently running
six minutes over.
Yeah, this is tight. Like, every
minute counts.
I'm just hoping I haven't given
myself vastly too much to do,
to go as fast as I can without
panicking.
Bakers, you have half an hour left!
This is going to be a tight finish.
Just want to curl up in a ball
and die quietly.
I've got to decorate everything.
It's not really on right.
Ugh!
It's about getting this angle right.
Caramel, it's very
difficult to work with.
It sticks really quick and if you've
not got it right, it ruins it.
Argh! Look at this.
I need to wash my hands.
HE EXHALES
Do you know what? It's not perfect,
but, at this stage, it's the best
I can do.
I'm just airbrushing a little
bit of silver on them now to try
and build colour bit by bit.
The colour's the most important
thing
cos Mexico is very vibrant and
colourful.
Putting some royal icing on my cups.
Green is the colour of the tea set I
was given.
This is royal icing.
It dries very quickly.
This is meant to be rough,
by the way.
I'm not happy with this,
I've gone for a terracotta,
but it's looking like a pinky orange
from here.
I love this. This is my favourite
part.
This could be it, this could be your
challenge. I hope so.
It depends what it tastes like,
though, Noel, doesn't it, really?
SHE EXHALES
And breathe.
Let's just decorate what I've got.
I'm rushing. Hate this.
Stop my hand from shaking. Come on.
And no, I'm not working to a design.
I have no design. I don't know
what I'm doing, if I'm honest.
Hopefully I can put a bit of
fondant rim on it once it dries.
I'm doing a semi-flood on this
biscuit.
Oh, it's cracked. It's definitely
been in a storm, this pot.
It's getting more and more rustic by
the moment.
That's good.
Let's try and work a bit quicker.
Just got the red dots to
put in the middle.
Attention to detail.
I enjoy the finishing touch,
make it look pretty.
I've literally had to say in my head
"Green, white, red,
green, white, red."
The spout was always a risky part.
Oh, dear, dear, dear, dear,
dear, dear, dear, dear.
Honestly, this looks like a child's
done it.
This is the most stressed I've ever
seen you. Yeah, yeah, it...
Shall I go? Yeah, could you?
Is that what you're trying to say?
Just be blunt with me,
I'm quite thick-skinned.
I'm ready... I'm ready for you to
leave now, Noel.
You're just in the way.
HE LAUGHS
I'll get that on my CV.
"You're just in the way."
The tea pot is so gaudy they're
going to say, "This is disgusting."
Right, come on, last push.
That's my structure.
This is my tea pot. Very delicate.
They look quite square.
They are square.
Square tea cups? Yes.
Is the tea square?
No, actually, it's sort of a
loose-leaf.
OK, that feels fairly robust.
Fingers crossed.
I need to fill my haggis with some
cranachan and that'll be me.
They're all done now.
I know it's not brilliant.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
What can we do in one minute with
a bit of gold leaf?
Just shaking so much.
Oh, my God, is time about to be up?
Bakers, your time is up.
SHE EXHALES
I think that'll do.
God, the pressure in this tent,
doing that.
Super happy. That went really well.
I think Paul will be pleased
it's largely finished.
It's judgement time for the
bakers' show stoppers.
Rowan, would you like to bring
up your show stopper, please?
I'm calling this
Worse Things Happen At Sea.
We did get your flashing lighthouse.
You get the flashing lighthouse.
Yeah, it does look like a
lighthouse.
It does look a bit smaller
than a lighthouse.
Little bit smaller. Yeah.
Is this gingerbread?
It's all a lemon...
Biscuit.
Lovely flavour.
That's been worked so much.
It's too thick. Tastes like rubber,
which is a shame cos actually
the flavour's not bad.
I sort of feel it's not your best,
Rowan.
I know you can do more.
It's a bit disappointing.
It's got a bit of a
Roger Hargreaves vibe.
Yeah. It looks brilliant.
The toast, the rack, the knife,
the way that you've done
the buttercream and that,
it just looks great.
Thank you very much.
Because it's thick, which it needed
to be for the middle of the toast,
it's a bit squishy in the middle.
Sure, OK. But I rather like that.
Overall, I think you've done
an amazing job. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
They're a little bit clumsy,
but they're all uniform
and I do like the colour
on the outside.
It's beautifully done. Almost looks
as if you sprayed it on.
Thank you.
I'm not convinced on the flavour.
It's all quite bitter, isn't it?
See, it's got to taste good
as well as look good.
Underneath this is a stand, which
you've just put this on the top of.
I'm not convinced that that's had a
lot of work in it.
That's a lovely flavour.
The flavour of the biscuit's
quite nice -
it's got a nice kick to
it as well from the spices -
but in four hours, we wanted
something a little bit neater.
You've certainly made it
very pretty.
It really is extremely well done.
The biscuit itself has been worked
a little bit too much
so the texture's not quite there.
It was always going to be an issue
if you go with a shortbread,
but I think the design is
very, very pretty.
It certainly looks very African.
Scruffy, but it looks the part.
SHE COUGHS
LAUGHTER
Strong, innit?
It's lovely.
Very strong coffee flavour.
I really like that flavour,
don't you? Hmm.
You didn't like it before.
You'll be awake all night, Paul.
I love the colours.
It's so Mexican, isn't it?
Yeah. It's beautiful.
That is remarkable.
We were looking for form
and shaping and moulding,
and I think you've done an amazing
job. Thank you.
It's very believable.
That is lovely.
Thank you. Mm. Mm.
That's actually delicious, yeah.
So, overall, I think you've done
a really good job there.
Thank you.
We were looking for moulding.
You've gone flat.
I know that the teapot's not
moulded,
but I quite like the look of it.
That looks a bit bendy.
I like the flavour.
Not much ginger.
It's not a bad flavour, though.
I just think the whole thing's just
a little bit clumsy, that's all.
You needed more care,
to be more precise.
Thank you, Mak. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
It looks rushed to me.
You're normally very neat.
That's not neat.
It's just the icing that is rushed.
I agree. Great flavour, though.
Great snap. Thank you.
Really crispy. Tastes delicious.
Hmm. Really nice. Very good.
Thank you. Thank you.
I like that. I think it looks very
neat, doesn't it?
Hmm. It's quite effective.
So that's the cranachan. Mm-hm.
The mixture of oatmeal, whisky,
raspberries.
Honey and cream.
Mm.
It's delicious.
You couldn't even finish the word
"delicious",
it was so delicious. Mmm.
Prue's in ecstasy.
I mean, it's very witty.
And, actually, the biscuit's
beautiful.
It's well baked, it's tasty.
Overall I think you've done a
great job. Thank you very much.
It's very impressive.
I think the boat's there.
It's a shame you ran out of time cos
it's gone a little bit
all over the place, but you've
moulded it quite nicely.
Erm... The plate looks a bit rough.
It is Viking. It's been under
the ground for the last 500 years
or something. Thanks, Prue.
It's good gingerbread. Very crisp,
lovely flavour, lots of ginger.
It has got a nice flavour to it.
Overall, I think you've
done a decent job. Very good.
I think they could see the vision,
which is really reassuring.
SHE EXHALES
Yeah, I reckon I got away with that.
Flavours I think might pull me
through.
Biscuit week wasn't my strongest.
If I do make it through this round,
it would be some kind of miracle.
Hopefully, you know, the judges will
look favourably upon me.
I think my position is more than
precarious, really.
I think it's completely tipped over
onto the slidey slope to, er,
oblivion.
It's decision time for Prue and
Paul.
Who'll be named star baker
and who will leave the tent?
So who do you think did the best
in that last challenge there?
David's table setting was very good.
Absolutely lovely. I adored it
and then I liked...
Mark, yeah... Mark.
His Ethiopian tea set.
I think Marc E had a really good
week. I really loved that.
Very clever. The texture, the look,
it's very neat.
So the Marks...
Top marks for the Marks!
LAUGHTER
We've got a few people in the mix
for star baker, but when it
comes to who's going home, it's
difficult between Mak and Rowan.
Which of those two do you think is
the most likely to improve
if they stay?
Well, I have to say Rowan
doesn't seem to take any advice.
I mean, Paul has been saying to him,
"Try not to promise too much
and, for goodness' sake, finish,"
and he hasn't done it once yet.
You just want his execution to be
better because he has great ideas.
I know. On the other hand, Mak
is steady, good.
But he's not blowing your mind,
is he?
Yeah, he's not blowing my mind.
I sense that you're torn.
We'd better leave you to go
and make your decision.
Fortunately for me,
I've got the great job of
announcing who is star baker.
And star baker this week is...
..Dave.
Thank you. Well done, you.
Thank you.
So it falls to me to announce
who will be going home this week.
I've never done it before and
I've been dreading this moment.
I will say that it was very close
and it involved a lot of
discussion, but I'm afraid to say
the baker going home this week is...
..Mak.
Thank you.
Oh. Sorry, man.
I'm expecting that. Thank you very
much. Unlucky, Mak.
OK, no, no, it's OK.
I just felt it in my bones that it
was me.
I know that I gave everything.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to miss you.
It was a privilege to be here,
meeting new people,
making new friends.
It's just been amazing.
Oh, Mak, honestly, I'm astonished.
My ideas saved me this week.
Last, last chance saloon.
I did my... I tried my hardest.
Just rein it in a little bit.
Going into next week, I'll hope to
manage the technical side
of things rather better.
I'm happy that I'm through, but I'm
really gutted that Mak's gone.
He's such a lovely guy.
It hurts. I'm going to miss him.
Can't believe it, I'm through!
The coffee was really strong
and they got a real kick from it.
It's quite nice to hear that I'll be
keeping Paul and Prue up all night.
It's been a good week for me.
I'm ecstatic. That was amazing.
Super happy.
Yeah!
I'm star baker this week.
Oh, my God!
I know, I can't... No way.
Yeah, I can't believe it.
I'm so proud of you.
What an end to the week.
Ooh! Well done!
Next time...
Whack it... it's bread week.
Listen to me, Paul Hollywood.
No-one under the age of 40 eats
bread any more.
As the bakers face a soda bread
signature...
You invented a bread!
..the tent reaches boiling point...
And breathe.
..in a nerve-twisting technical...
Woo-oo!
I really don't know what
I'm looking for.
..and it's all about growth...
Arise, sir dough.
..in the loaf...
No time for faffery.
..in a sensational show stopper.
Very, very good.
Who will dance their way to
success...
..and who'll be left crying...
BLEEP
..over spilt milk?
LAUGHTER
It's not funny!
Yuck.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media